[Music]
well welcome back to another episode of
the addie hour
i'm grateful to be able to continue to
lead these conversations and discussions
i think this is going to be another
great discussion today as well today
we're going to be focusing on the topic
of trauma and really digging into the
science of trauma
and so i'm thrilled to be able to
welcome today's two guests i've been
really eager to have this joint
conversation with both of them and
extending conversation
so i'm grateful that they've been
willing to jump in so our first
guest is dr bianca jones marlin dr
bianca jones martin is an assistant
professor of psychology
and of neuroscience at columbia and
zuckerman institute
and i have to say one shocking thing
about this today is this is actually our
first time
interacting and i say that's shocking
because i'm definitely familiar with her
work
both her scientific work and her
outreach work in the community
and i've heard her name for years from
lots of mutual colleagues and mutual
friends
so i feel honored that we actually have
this time to finally interact and i'm
really grateful that she's been willing
to jump into the conversation
but just to mention briefly bianca has
done stellar work
as a as a scientist throughout her
career even going back to
graduate school when she was focused on
oxytocin and looking at its effects on
maternal behavior
one of the other things i really
appreciate about bianca is the work that
she's been doing recently really looking
at these transgenerational effects and
how
experiences in one generation can
influence the brains and the experiences
of subsequent generations in offspring
so i know that's something we're also
going to be talking about as well also
deeply appreciative for the work that
she does
around gender equity and racial
disparities within the scientific
community and
within community at large so grateful to
have bianca on the program today with us
thanks for being here
thank you for having me of course our
second guest is dr
carrie ressler dr ressler is a scientist
and a physician at mclean hospital and
also at harvard medical school he's a
chair of psychiatry at mclean
also the chief of the division of
depression and anxiety disorders and the
chief scientific officer
so just a few a few titles there
obviously someone who's deeply invested
in this area as well
as i mentioned he's a scientist and a
physician and has done a lot of work
really thinking about the molecular
processes in the brain that are
important for emotion
and fear and anxiety but also does human
genetic work as well and so we've been
able to bridge those two worlds very
effectively
i have to say that one of the things
that i'm really deeply appreciative with
him
is i had the opportunity to hear him
give a talk at a scientific conference
years ago
hadn't met him yet but i was really
deeply impressed by his commitment
to his work specifically the work that
he was doing in many
marginalized communities around aspects
and things like trauma
and the effects of just the experiences
that happen in those communities
and how these things can lead to
post-traumatic stress disorder he's been
thinking about things like
um susceptibility to substance use and
aspects of violence and for me i was
really just
um to be to be honest i was completely
i don't want to stay enamored but
surprised to see someone of your stature
that was so
invested in the community and i know a
lot of that was done through the grady
project
um he was at emory for 18 years and was
leading that project i'm sure we'll hear
more about that today
but just deeply grateful that you've
been doing this work for so long and i'm
grateful that both of you
are willing to come on here together and
have this conversation with one another
so welcome to the program dr ressler
thanks so much dr eddie it's really a
pleasure really looking forward to the
conversation
um and clearly this is something that is
a topic of interest to us as a society
i know that even in my own experiences
as i've been hosting different events
over the years it's a phrase that comes
up
much more frequently than in the past so
people will talk about
you know the fact that trauma can be
passed on at the molecular level
that's something i think we can really
unpack in this conversation
but even before we go there i do like to
often just check in with guests and see
how you're both doing obviously there's
a lot that's happening in our society
right now we're in the middle of the
shaving trial
and all the emotions that brings up
we're continuing to deal with all the
racial injustices
we're seeing the continuation and up
upsurge of anti-erasure anti-asian
racism
and so i think it's a lot for us to deal
with now i just like to see how
people are doing in the midst of
everything that's going on so bianca if
you'd be willing to jump in and start
at that at that place yes i am you're
you're
i think we're starting off on um with a
very uh
heavy emoted uh a question i think we
usually possibly say like oh we're doing
great
um i can't say i'm doing 100 um as you
ask that question like pinch my fingers
they don't get too emotional it's a lot
and it's very loaded right now i don't
think that everyone is always aware of
that
and so i think for some of us who it
affects or maybe
i would hope it would affect everyone
equally but for those who
seem to feel a stronger pull
um towards social injustice it is a
little bit hard so it's been a rough on
a few days i would say yeah well i
definitely appreciate your honesty
and sharing that as well because i think
that that is part of what we're
trying to do here not to just have that
passive
oh everything's fine everything's fine
you know and there's
there's a reason that we we go to that
place i mean there is a level of
vulnerability that comes and we have to
know that people are actually really
willing and ready to listen
but here i think it's so important to
just to just be honest
and not to detour too early in the
conversation but i think for many of us
who are
in educational spaces that's important
for our students and trainees too to not
pretend that we're doing better than we
are and to create the space for them to
be able to say okay they're also
struggling and then it actually builds
the community
um as well so i appreciate you exactly
not just my trainings yeah yeah so
important
what about you carrie how are you how
are you managing with everything so far
yeah i think you know it's been um quite
a year in so many ways
um from all of the
you know i think from the from the
racial justice movements and black lives
matter movements
i think you know for those of us who in
many ways those of us in mental health i
think are eternally optimistic
it feels like you know maybe this is the
time it feels like you know since
you know at every step along the last
200 years and certainly through the 60s
and civil rights movements and through
the 70s
kept being like okay we're making
progress now and and hopefully we are
but there's certainly many many places
of
systemic racism and institutionalized
racism that we haven't haven't figured
it out yet and
i grew up in mississippi and um
so there's a you know i think we as
those of us who
you know i think all of us have have
different levels of privilege but
certainly
you know very aware of how i and we as
as leadership needs to do better
and um so i think it's such a call to
action and i just hope that
you can really make make it matter in
more so
more important ways this time so thank
you for hosting this and for this
conversation because this is i think
a wonderful way to explore these issues
in a much more deeply um
yeah i definitely appreciate that and i
appreciate your
your acknowledgement of the privilege
that comes with that too in a way you're
saying both privilege and responsibility
to not just privilege but to actually
take steps to move forward and at the
same time it sounds like you're trying
to be i mean
in a lot of ways you're both being
realistic there are aspects of pain
that's real we can't avoid that there
are aspects of optimism but there are
also aspects of
well we've done this before and let's
not get stuck in that same cycle
of just kind of repeating the lip
service and just going back to the way
things were
so i think that's so that's so important
i appreciate your
acknowledgement of what we're trying to
do with this this podcast as well to
make sure that
we can really talk about the things that
aren't always talked about just kind of
get
i don't want to say buried under the
service but get left kind of in that
space of well we don't really want to
touch that
and bianca i know you've done a lot of
that you know over the last year as well
um carrie i know through our
interactions that's been a focus for you
so again i'm just grateful grateful to
both of you
for the way that you're pulling all
those things together it's not easy not
easy
in any sense of the word so carrie you
hinted a little bit about your
background i did want to
dig in a little bit deeper there and
actually ask both of you how you got to
this place
in your lives of being deeply invested
in neuroscience research
especially for those in our audience who
aren't scientists
i'm sure they'd be curious to hear why
why are the two of you so deeply
invested in this this area so care if
you could
talk a little bit about your journey i
guess both to medicine and to
neuroscience research how did you come
to that place
sure um sort of a brief
background so i grew up in mississippi
um from multiple generations
in this house and first generation
college um from a single parent
household
um so while although i was white uh my
you know mom grew up in segregationist
mississippi and
her best friends were black and where
she lived in the country and
so really heard the stories of of what
that was like
um so it was always very aware you know
had a very progressive
mother in um you know early 70s
mississippi
and so was you know very aware of racial
injustice
from there so that side and then i was
also you know working in a grocery store
and
um you know everything else to just get
by and fortunately had great math
teachers and great teachers and and had
the opportunity to to do well and i was
sort of a child of the first generation
of computer sci
of of you know computers um so i um
was applying to college and my math
teacher said you should look at mit and
i'm like what is mit
and so i was fortunate enough to get
into my tv and i went there to be a
computer scientist i thought um
um i i'm still convinced that i got it
at mit because i was a token mississippi
person but
i'll take it but along the way
um i i was really exposed for the first
time to molecular
biology and neuroscience and this
absolutely fell in love with it um
you know in the 80s seeing this sort of
molecular generate
revolution that you could really
engineer biology
seemed much more exciting to me than
engineering program computers
so long story short um did that was in
um on the fence between
neuroscience and medicine i worked in
emergency departments and worked in
medicine was really wanted to give back
to the community but loved research
so i was fortunate enough to get into an
md phd program and stay in boston at
harvard
and um that's where i met linda buck i
was i was doing research
um i was looking doing my rotations for
what i was going to do my phd in
and um couldn't quite find the right one
i want to do plasticity
my learning in memory and there weren't
many people at harvard at the time and
then somebody said you should come here
this job talk
um by this [ __ ] person and so i went not
knowing
anything about smell in my life and um
linda black and richard axel who y'all
will hear from
bianca had just discovered the odor
receptor gene family and i just opened
my eyes to a whole way that one could
use molecular tools
to understand a sensory system and
really for the last 30 years since then
been you know using molecular tools to
understand
systems neuroscience questions um and as
we get into the later discussion about
some of the intergenerational stuff
it was it was that background and
olfaction um that was really exciting so
from there did a postdoc at emory in
atlanta um i moved to atlanta for a
number of reasons um it's a great
program my wife was from there
and we had a baby all of those things um
and
grady tri um hospitals one of the main
teaching hospitals in atlanta and i
really wanted to give back
and train at grady um and so while both
working with michael davis there on fear
um and he was one of the founders of the
amygdala systems i started using
molecular biology approaches to
understanding the amygdalin fear
also was a approach began to understand
what ptsd was in the
veterans populations and in my work and
as a psychiatrist at grady really saw
that trauma was everywhere and yet we
weren't paying attention to it
and so that really began our 20-year
journey into understanding
trauma in the inner city and since then
we've um interviewed almost 13 000
people coming to grady hospital just for
general medical care
in that process i've learned a lot about
trauma exposure just the enormity of it
the enormity of ptsd and depression and
comorbidity so really i've spent
a lot of my years in trying to
understand by by understanding the
medical model and neuroscience approach
to trauma
cannot really help us have better
interventions and improvements so that's
me i've otherwise been married for 30
years
have a couple dogs and three boys and um
i'm very grateful for um
the life i've had thank you that's great
well thanks for sharing the journey i
mean even going all the way back to the
beginning that was very impressive by
the way the way you succinctly
encapsulate so many aspects of your life
story
but i appreciate that i think it's
helpful for people to just get the
the entire context too i mean even going
back to your family history and
your first generation experiences and
the opportunities that you're able to
to take advantage of definitely
appreciate that i know we'll tie back
and think even more deeply about some of
the work that you're currently doing
during now as well but just grateful for
the investment that you've made in a lot
of ways
thank you and bianca what about you i
know you shared some of your story in
other settings before both in terms of
your scientific journey
um and your family background growing up
and and your
thoughts about teaching how all that led
you to this to this place so curious to
have you expand on that a little bit
here as well
yes i'm so happy to expand i'm i'm a
little bit overwhelmed
at the amazing parallel between
carrie and myself um i don't think like
just taking a brief like look at us
any there's anything that's similar
outside of like we're both gray
um hair color wise but i i'm i'm so
taken aback so um
and so thank you so much for sharing
especially like some aspects um that i
have found as i
as i continue on in science that are
sometimes hard to share like um
openly like struggles coming from a
single family home coming from like
maybe a low ses
i've been very hesitant to share these
things there's only as a recently that i
realized that
me sharing this i'm inspiring people who
don't know that they assume differently
about me that like oh they can actually
do this it's possible not hardly
possible so i am
i am a new yorker through and through
born and raised
i'm very proud of that so i can't
pronounce words like draw it's totally
fine
you say it too often in science and
everyone's always confused this is the
draw that's fine
um i'm from new york uh boarding queens
and um
i'm first generation american on one
side my mother was born in guyana south
america
my dad is in new york through and
through for a few generations um
although i do have family from right
outside of birmingham my gran my
grandmother was born right outside of
birmingham so one side is black america
and the other side is guyanese
and uh i from my perspective i had like
an extremely happy and amazing
childhood and i do think that it's only
in retrospect that i realized how
like uniquely set up my childhood was
and inspiring what i do now um so i grew
up in a
my parents my biological parents um but
they were foster parents as well so i
had foster siblings and adopted siblings
which allowed me um insight into other
people's
world and life without ever like i'm so
thankful
without ever having to experience it
because a lot of these things are
associated with trauma if you are
in the foster care system it's because
you have um a caregiver who wasn't able
to
live up to that definition of caregiver
and no shame
associated with the character and i feel
that very strongly that's also why i
study parental behavior because we can't
always say it's like the parent's issue
or the child's issue there's a lot of
things involved with that but i was able
to get a little bit of insight into how
it is to live in
a home that wasn't like mine um and i
think that really motivated me to go
into education so i first started off as
a teacher
um it's amazing that gary said someone
said
go check out mit and you're like what is
mit um i i started going into education
and i saw a sign that said like do you
want i'm in college that says
i went to st john's and queens i
literally have never i haven't left new
york
my undergrad grad school post soccer
ball here um
and uh i saw like a flyer that said that
you can go to uh get a
free tuition if you work in a lab i was
like that sounds great i was an
education major
um and i started doing fungal genetics
and it entered me into like the world of
like um
science like they asked like uh you know
what does a phd stand for and i was like
i didn't know what to say for and like i
learned more about phd
and presenting that data at a conference
called abrahams it's the annual
biomedical research conference for
minority students
i had um someone come up to me at dean
he's like oh you should check out my
school
um mit for a summer program being from
new york i know mit
i know nyi team new york institute of
technology which is like a little school
in my town i was like
i guess if i want to go to massachusetts
sure i'll check it out
and it was that same year that a movie
came out called 21 which is about like
some brilliant mit
uh mathematicians who go to um vegas and
like they game the system and win a
whole lot of money
and i was like i knew some of the people
in that group did you
sorry of course mit is a big deal
oh i should i should pull this
application out i did not know um
so that was one of my phrases into
neuroscience i worked in a lab there for
the summer
i learned more about neuroscience and i
think during that the path of being part
of this program which is for um
first generation student college
students which i was the first in my
family to go to college and graduate
first generation americans low ses all
the things i checked off um
the program that got me that introduced
me to to this
research really allowed me to align the
fact that i loved
teaching i loved the concept of learning
i wanted to understand how
environmental factors like stress like
trauma made it different from my
siblings to navigate school and for me
like
i was a pretty solid straight a student
i knew my siblings had the capabilities
to do
that but i just think environmental
factors did not allow them to
focus on that because there was so much
more going on um and so
within getting the science component the
learning and then being introduced to
neuroscience of the these summer
programs i went to
i decided i want to study learning and
memory as opposed to being the teacher
and i did teach seventh grade 10th grade
in ap biology for a year before i
entered into grad school um and it was a
for any graduate students listening i
had a very interesting graduate school
career like
i did five rotations most people do
three i'm in a lab to find where you
want to go
um and the fifth rotation was with with
uh uh robert funke dr robert funke
and he was like you can do some of this
stuff some of this stuff i have a slight
interest in like maternal behavior and i
was like oh that's me that's what i want
to do i understand
behavior and it led to the oxytocin
project um that a large percentage of
his lab is now looking at
um and similarly when it came to looking
into my post doc
i had a few offers on the the my phd
work um
was very well received and we found some
pretty amazing groundbreaking
groundbreaking um
results uh that led me to offers to
start my own lab prior to even doing a
postdoc and so i looked into
um those but uh meeting richard axel who
i wanted to do my postdoc with who is
also here at columbia
who won the nobel prize with linda buck
who
carried his own carry worked with um he
a convinced me that new york is where
where i want to stay he's really good at
that he's also new yorker um and b that
i can
learn a new facet i also didn't think i
would be interested in odor uh my former
work was listen uh was uh
um auditory um so listening it's a
beautiful stimulus you play a tone you
see a response in the brain like
humidity doesn't change it you can wear
perfume and like odor is very different
um but the questions you can ask with a
beautiful system like the old factory
system just opened my mind to like
my eyes to so many aspects
and the fact that we can associate
trauma
and memory with things like what grandma
was cooking in the kitchen and the smell
of the apple pie
just it excites me as to where we can
where we can take this field
and so now i'm assistant professor at
columbia um studying how trauma's passed
down through generations and how
parents play a role in this and how
environmental factors like smell
and sound and taste and the senses take
in the world and keep those memories in
and pass those memories on
well that's that's so uh inspiring and
humbling at the same time to hear you
share your story and i'm struck
i mean you said this yourself right but
how many intersections and overlaps
you and kerry have even the interjection
about the mit folks
i mean there's just wow so
scientifically and otherwise and i think
i mean that's
the beauty of of the work we do
sometimes i think too and
to be honest i think it's it also speaks
to the importance of sometimes
us having conversations outside of our
specific scientific
question and discipline not there's
anything wrong with that i mean we all
get really excited about that but
there's so much more
sometimes i think that we don't have the
chance to appreciate uh because we are
stuck in that kind of framework about
only speaking about things in one way so
obviously that's maybe that's a
self-serving comment because that's one
of the things that i'm really trying to
do
on the addie hour too just to be able to
pull in so many different topics and
make sure that we can
unearth all those pieces as well so
definitely appreciate you bianca sharing
sharing those components and
and carry as well there's so many
different directions that we could go i
mean to be honest this almost feels like
it could be a three-hour conversation
but one thing that i did want to pull
out um from something you both mentioned
too is just
you know how you got interested in
bianchi tasha on the survey too but
about
trauma specifically just because
clearly that's something that has a lot
of societal implications i think in a
lot of ways in the last year
as a broader society both of you have
been thinking about this already but
we're starting to pay much more
attention
to that than we have in the past i'm so
curious to hear
even a little bit more about how you got
invested in that and then if you could
also just unpack this idea of
the cellular molecular ways that trauma
gets passed on
what does that what does that actually
mean because that phrase as i mentioned
gets thrown around a lot
um i think it's it's good that people
are paying attention to it but i think
it's also important that we
really have a good understanding and to
be honest that's an illness that i think
we as scientists have to communicate
that
um so care if we go ahead and start with
you so well as you say we could probably
talk for 10 hours on those two topics
i'll try to give you a very short
version and we can dive deeper
um so for me um i was interested in
trauma as
a psychiatrist who
wanted to combine so really two sides
one the intellectual side
i found that um our understanding in the
late 90s of the amygdala
and the brain circuit regions that
encode the fear
and threat responses were some of the
best understood brain circuits
that we had in mammals and so i i
as a physician scientist i really wanted
to study something that i could both
understand more mechanistically in an
animal system
and understand something relevant
relevant to humans so i was very
attracted to ptsd the purely
intellectual question but i also really
you know i went into medicine and wanted
to do something
related to helping people but um from
both my
mississippi and earlier backgrounds and
seeing racial injustice i really wanted
to do something that could eventually
help the community i knew i wasn't going
to be a policy wonk i wasn't really who
i was but if i could do something
scientifically
that would speak to community issues
that would be a lovely way to combine
them and for me
started when my eyes were opened up
working at grady as
an intern the first year residency and
was interviewing people
in our general um so so grady hospital
is the main receiving area the main
trauma hospital for all of
atlanta's five plus million people and
they're also the main psychiatric
receiving facility
and you know you'll be thrown in there
as an early resident not really knowing
much of anything and you're supposed to
interview people and make decisions
and um what i found first is that nobody
quite fit our different diagnostic
criteria everybody you know there was
substance abuse
there was depression there was
suicidality there was psychosis
and all of it was kind of mixed up and
certainly substance was underlying a lot
of it
but having come from the va and seen the
the ptsd in the veterans
to me it was very obvious as soon as we
started asking people about trauma it
was everywhere
and it was almost like in the 1800s we
called syphilis kind of the great
mimicker and i think trauma is kind of a
great miracle for it
whether down medical comorbidities or
psychiatric comorbidities or other
components
so i just i was fascinated with it and
so for me being able to look at
trauma from both the basic side
understand ptsd
and start to really help understanding
your voice to
civilian trauma and in at-risk
communities
and how that also speaks to the cycle of
violence and the cycle of risk
we're all fascinating to me in humans so
maybe i'll pause there
and then we can maybe do a second round
when we start talking about the details
of the intergenerational work
yeah that sounds great uh thanks for
just sharing that context as well i
think that's really helpful for people
to know
what motivated you and and it's
inspiring again to hear
that you were paying attention to what
to what you saw in front of you i think
that's something that comes up in a lot
of our conversations too
especially as we go through the mental
health whether the providers are
basically putting their categories on to
people
or listening to people's stories and it
sounds like in a lot of ways you were
watching and listening to the stories
and the experiences that you saw in
front of you and saying okay what is
that leading me to
rather than the other way around i think
that's really important yeah just to
interject
the number of people that we would see
with diagnosis you know there's
certainly plenty of schizophrenia in
bipolar and severe depression
but there's a lot of folks with very
severe trauma and underlying ptsd that i
think are either misdiagnosed or they're
putting their priorities in the wrong
place
yeah yeah really important and again a
whole other conversation which we may
pull in later but even the disparities
that come along that
as well in terms of racialism and black
people are much more likely
to be diagnosed with severe mental
illness than um than
being then identifying the underlying
trauma yeah
so bianca to pivot back to you we've
pulled out a lot but you shared some of
that already from your you know your
childhood experiences too but were there
other components that
pulled you into this work or things that
are kind of ongoing for you
i think it's we as scientists we walk
the line between what do the data say
and what do we know as humans like what
what are we into it
and the data we're still parsing this
out
um we're still ironing out what
mechanisms could be and that's okay
right like
i need to have a job so i'm fine with
that we don't have all the answers there
but we know as humans
when we think about um finding a partner
a lot of people ask like
what kind of family do they come from
what have they gone through
what are their parents like we know that
certain elements
are imprinted into into people
we know that people who have gone
through war we just intuit that
potentially there could be some
something that that language i'm
a military family my brother serves that
serves in the united states military
um maybe and there's certain elements
when he was you know
out and he came back that we would want
to ask to see how he was feeling
i didn't need data to know that if you
came from an abusive household you were
sexually or physically emotionally
abused
that that has ramifications i didn't
need to look at your
their epigenetic changes um because we
know these things as humans
and so i think that in understanding
that we get this as humans
i'm confident that as we get this the
data will come
rolling um and so i think that's that's
what i try to go back to when stuff is
hard in in the lab and we can't we can't
really put our finger on what it is that
we're looking for
i just look at society like we know
these things as as human beings and so
there's got to be an underlying written
script there for the behavioral outputs
that we see
yeah i think that's really important in
so many ways and you're right that line
i'm glad you brought up because i think
we sometimes we walk that line without
acknowledging that we walk that line
i imagine that for both of you that
might be something that's talked about
more often than in other circles but i
think it's a principle that
a lot of us should be thinking about
more explicitly um as well
and i even you know even the pieces that
you pulled out about
how to really think about the data
versus what we know
inherently in front of us is really
important i'm curious if you could
expand a little bit on this idea of
who's what's often characterized as
who's at fault
because you're into that too because you
hinted at the fact that if you know you
know your brother is coming back from a
difficult situation
you all have some grace in how you're
thinking about what experiences he had
but i think a lot of times
when we're talking about underserved
communities there's this narrative that
gets framed that
while you also just pull yourselves up
by your bootstraps why are you
you know putting the fault on the
victims in a sense
i'm just curious how you think about
that both in terms of society-wise and
in terms of your research
on bianca if you want just expand that
little of course yes that's a very
important question and i fully support
pulling yourself out from your
bootstraps if you have boots
and i think that's the issue when i
speak about or when i think about
like my experience growing up in my
foster siblings and i want to make sure
i'm very clear like i'm not speaking
from them or their perspective i'm
speaking as myself with
true loving caring parents um and the
things i learned from them i don't ever
want to be their voice but i do want to
share my experience with them
they came from abusive households
where their parents tried the best they
could
to manage their children under the
stress as they were stressors they had
after coming from abusive households
and so it's not as if like this just
magically
erupted in like their lineage this is
generation upon generation upon
generation
of suppression of abuse of of of
of substance abuse but these aren't
things that we can just target to one
person because
and i for all i know like some of the
people who came from these households
who became my siblings
could also then have parents have
children and have to
grapple with the way that they parent
their kids and what they learned
and we see this aligned in in a lot of
our research
there is a rodent research that's shown
that if you have a
mother who smells like peppermint
and then you have a and her offspring
and you shock her offspring while she's
next to the mom with peppermint
even though the animals felt shock so i
felt pain surrounding the mom
it still prefers peppermint and so
there's something innate about saying
like although i know that this is not a
good situation i do want to go back to
this parent i do want to go back to my
to my mother um and how much of that can
be parsed out society
societally by saying like your mother
was horrible you could not be like this
person your father was horrible you
cannot be like this person and like
having the pull to love it and so i i do
find that something that i
it's hard to parse out in the science
because you want something clean
crisp like the day to say this but there
are emotions involved with parenthood
there are emotions involved with with um
with generations to come and what that
looks like and you know in rodents which
is what i use to study my um
look at my question is it's hard to not
turn anthropomorphize that
yeah that's a really pretty example go
ahead okay yeah sorry it's beautifully
said beyonce
you know it's kind of bringing it back
to the big story and i really see that
that's
so much an issue with institutional
racism i think you can even have people
meaning well oh there's you know they
don't understand we don't understand but
there's just so many false equivalencies
that wait you know doesn't matter what
happened to you when you're early we're
now giving you
school opportunity we're giving you you
know some food we're giving you a head
start
we're getting a job why aren't things
better there's this just
lack of appreciation that these things
that we know are critical for our
developmental like you said but even
with the topic of this potentially even
intergenerational
that we've got to do more you can't just
have a head start program you can't just
have a job opportunity if if the
building block the emotional building
blocks aren't there in addition to the
out of the new opportunities
it's not going to work so you don't have
the boots even though it may look like
you have them so there's the false
equivalencies of okay we'll give them
now but they're just
it's not the same and we haven't as a
society learn that or figure out what to
do about that
yeah yeah i think that's so important
and i i appreciate the fact that
you're pulling that out to both of you
that we have we can see those
society-wise
um as well we don't have to wait for all
the data to know that that's true
but even at the same time care if you
could just expand on what the data has
started to show us
about how those processes are actually
happening
in terms of what bianca already brought
up sure so um you know one of the things
uh
so sort of stories that we've been most
excited about is this concept of
epigenetics so i think most people
are kind are familiar with the idea of
genetics that's what you're born with
your dna it's in your cells
and you know essentially we all come
from a mix of our moms and our dads
genes but over the last couple decades
it's really understood that there's this
concept of epigenetics how the genes can
be altered
and data for a number of years have
suggested that
developmental trauma be that neglect
abuse physical sexual emotional abuse
that's more associated with all bad
things basically whether it be
whether it be you know medical
psychological substance abuse
risk etc and they're we're starting to
understand that
see marks both in your blood and in the
brain the ways in which the genes have
been altered
via this early developmental experience
through this epigenetic term
and so that's one way that we're
starting to understand how the biology
of development
may hold on and be kind of stuck there
during adulthood
and one for example that we've been
involved with a lot is a gene that's
involved in the stress regulatory system
and the epigenetic changes in some of
these genes
alter how the body and the mind respond
to stress and that looks very different
if you've had childhood trauma versus
not and likely very much
tunes the stress system and the body and
the brain very differently in adulthood
and then the work where bianca and i met
and and share
scientific excitement is um we both
start you know in the olfactory system
i've been working for a few years and
then had transitioned over to studying
fear and amygdala
but for all the reasons bianca said the
olfactory system is so fascinating and
one of which is because we can structure
we have molecular tools that allow us to
see the structural
organization of how smell works in the
nose and in the brain
part of the brain called the olfactory
bowl and we found
based on really inspired by work by many
scientists over decades
where they showed that if you had early
experiences it changed the structure of
the brain and you had different sensory
systems
and we were able to show that if you
even had an adult
because of the term what we know now is
that there's turnover constantly in the
olfactory system that's why if somebody
has a cold or covered now and loses
smell
eventually it comes back because the
cell the cells grow back so that
suggests that there's this ongoing
plasticity in the in the olfactory
system that may be different than other
sensory systems
and so we found that if you train an
animal to be afraid of so you shock them
with a cherry smell
but the specific molecular markers of
cherry
actually increase in the nose and
increase in the brain so you have an
increased representation
and increased behavioral sensitization
of that cherry
and the molecular mechanisms of that are
starting to be understood
and a brilliant postdoc named brian diaz
in the lab wanted to look at this in
broader ways and basically
almost randomly he he planned it i was
very surprised but found that if you
train if you
shock basically traumatize a father
before they give birth
to this cherry smell the offspring
actually are more sensitive to cherry
have more representation of cherry in
the nose and more representation of
cherry in the brain
and you show that in lots of different
ways that even if you
just take the sperm of the father after
they've been traumatized and do what we
call in vitro fertilization take it to a
different place
no behavioral interaction at all the
next generation
still had these molecular and structural
and behavioral marks
of increased sensitization to this
trauma smell suggesting that at least
one sensory system the olfactory system
is able to hold on to somehow some of
this olfactory information that is
important across the across generations
and that has so many implications that
we can talk about
thanks so my way of getting to know
bianca was i heard these rumors that
there was somebody from the axle lab who
replicated some of the work
and we all got very excited in that a
year and a half
being anxiously awaiting her to hear
more about it
yeah i mean that speaks to the
scientific endeavor too and i'm curious
actually to
even piggyback on that and see just to
hear from both your friends but how did
people
first respond to the work
i'll let carrie answer that because i i
heard that in parallel as i was making a
decision as to what i was going to
focus my post-doctoral work on and um my
post-doctoral advisor was like
are you sure you want to study this
because i know that you never truly find
that you can't do your relationship
run away
but it goes back to what i was saying
what we know these things like
intuitively as humans but it's so hard
to convince people that the data of what
we're showing is like is
is relevant so i'll let kerry answer
that question because i'm yeah
the brief answer is skepticism lots and
lots of skepticism
there's you know other work by people
like um isabel mansooi and tracy dale
in germany and maryland who've done
other great work in showing
intergenerational stress
the problem is the stress system is
really complicated and it's kind of
nuanced and there's not really very
specific molecules all the time
and i think what the olfactory system
has going for us and why this
story from all of our groups um is so
powerful
is that we do have these very precise
markers and you can
you have these molecular markers for one
smell versus another smell so you have
this built-in control
to show that you can have this
inheritance that affects one smell
system but not the up not so it's one
odor but not another
and that allowed us to overcome it but
but all the skepticism certainly made
the paper better and made us do a lot
more of the
gazillion extra experiments to really
show this this is a real phenomena we
don't know what it means
but we know it's in the sperm and we
think it's epigenetics um
but what one kind of fun example is so
this comes back to this historical thing
of darwin versus lamarck what do you
inherit versus what can you change
um and everybody was saying oh this is
what mark is and we threw that out but
the problem is we didn't know about
epigenetics and we didn't know that
probably both are true at some level
and we were trying not to we were trying
to avoid that issue and just talk about
the data
and then nature neuroscience where it
came out without telling us put the mark
on the cover
that's how it works sometimes yeah
that's really helpful i think to know
that obviously it wasn't easy at the
time but to know the context too and the
pushback
um how would you say and maybe bianca
you can you can talk about this
did was that mirrored on the societal
side like how does society
as a collective respond to
the work i think that comes back to our
job as scientists by taking the data
and saying that these are the data that
we have we're in the process of
interpreting them
and i think that comes back to i don't
think i would say i know this comes back
to the fact that if
i'm flipping through a paper or i'm
flipping through a book or i'm i'm not a
scientist
i'm just reading like new york times or
something of the story and i see you've
had trauma in your past
and now you're ruined for life because
these epigenetic markers have now been
ingrained in your system and so you're
just like
you're out of luck um i would be pretty
offended
and i'd be angered because this person
this scientist doesn't know who i am
they don't know how i deal with things i
think that's the part that we need to
definitely highlight we don't know
exactly what we're looking at
we could be looking at something that
could align with ptsd
increased sensitivity to a
non-threatening cue
we could be looking at resilience the
ability of
the nose to then sent an odor that in
the past was traumatizing
but now i'm warned about it earlier
because i have more neurons that are
going to say
hmm or learn more quickly and so
the data remain the same but those two
explanations are how we interpret the
data
and i i like my goal as a scientist is
to take the
the data that we have and really
interpret it in mult with multiple
facets in a way that benefits society
and so i'm very hesitant when we speak
about trauma just trauma and trauma
because that could be
really traumatizing especially for
someone like me who's like a black woman
first generation scs like i don't want
to just swallow the fact that like okay
i have
generations upon generations of slavery
induced
trauma and now like i just can't live
like functionally maybe
maybe there's an element of resilience
that can be inherited as well
um and just remembering that i think it
gives me energy and joy and i do want to
tell the like i try to make sure that
the community and society at large and
it was like
these are just the data it could be in
something bad it could mean something
amazing
and we're in the process of figuring
that out yeah that's so good
nice to add to that too i think you know
so beautifully said you know and one of
the things i want to make sure that i
get in and always try to talk about this
is the latest work
that i think is so exciting is that if
you take the same fathers you traumatize
them to the cherry
but then you extinguish them you
essentially give them exposure therapy
just like we do review ptsd
and then you make them offspring look
just like nothing ever happened
so what to suggest is that all of these
processes are plastic
and if we know the right way to
intervene in the way to help further
build resilience
that these are plastic they're not fake
and that's i think really important
yeah really important points and
beautiful segway too because one of the
things
that often we try and talk about on the
adi hour so as me as a basic
neuroscientist obviously
like you i'm very focused on the
processes in the brain that are
contributing to these
challenges and also to resilience as
well but then i also
try hard not to talk about these things
only in the bubble so think about all
the other components that contribute to
emotional wellness
and to mental health challenges and to
coming through those mental health
challenges
so thinking about spiritual components
you know the social justice
racism all the different interventions
we have whether that be psychological
interventions
prayer meditation how all these things
impinge
um so i think it's always good for us to
have as you both mentioned that focus
but i'm curious
but you've both talked about this
already and carry even with that last
data
how do you see all those different types
of processes being important
in terms of how we think about mental
health in general
both from what you've seen in your data
and from a broader societal perspective
i realize that's a huge question but i'd
love to hear
your thoughts on both of those bianca if
you want to start
yes i i want uh entrance i want right
because they're following the data
and what i believe is that
biology has a setup for success not for
failure and any aspect that we're
inheriting or any epigenetic component
really in the proper framework is
for us to succeed in that environment
not to feel like like evolution doesn't
want us to
just crash and burn because it doesn't
have a job like we talked about having a
job
you could always tell them for 10 years
like good job
um yeah and so with that being said like
it
i i think that's the case like that
biology will always look out for us
that our brains and our bodies and those
adaptations that it goes through will
always look out for us
and so if we have the inkling to rest we
probably need to do that
if we have the inkling whatever that
rest looks like to you to pray to take a
second to read
to hang out with your whatever that
inkling is i suggest following that and
that's what i do in my life because i
trust what my body's saying um because
because humans have been around for this
long and we haven't knocked ourselves
off the planet yet and so it's
there's got to be something that i
should be listening to
that's so well said and still a lot to
unpack
as well yeah in terms of how all that
impacts our brains it moves us forward
what about you carrie
yeah i agree with all of that i think i
think and
you know to anthropomorphize a bit but
try to understand that you know the
reason why this might happen
you know we think about if if a mouse
grew up in one part
from apparently you know they might have
enough smell systems to be able to
smell 10 000 different odors but there
may only be 50 or 100 that really matter
for the last couple generations where
the parents
live for both where the food were and
where the prey was and if you could be
predisposed to be more sensitive to
those that would be really good
you know so we don't know what exactly
that means in humans and i think
everything you said is is
right on i think for how i think about
some of these things as a psychiatrist
is that it reminds me that you know one
of the
take-home tenets of psychiatry is that
our emotional responses are not always
what we think they are and they're not
always
what we consciously want they're what
are by our brain
because of our dna our epigenetics and
our lifetime experiences
emotionally have us respond to and
sometimes that's really helpful that gut
and other times it can keep getting us
stuck in a rut of behaviors that we may
not want
and i think this is one more place where
as we continue
to you know learn more about the human
condition and learn how we can all help
ourselves and help each other
it's figuring out what what things are
we responding to because that's where we
are in the present that's what we want
versus when are we responding to the
past and maybe we don't know it
yeah so well said as well there's so
many so many topics that you all are
pulling out
i know we're running close to the end of
our time uh may have to have both of you
back at some point one thing that i
did want to mention though and we didn't
talk about as much but it's just a theme
of community
as well so bianca i know that's
something that's come through your work
in a lot of ways
um and carrie as you're talking i sense
that that's there as well
even in terms of what you've done in the
grady project and one of the things that
i often that we've been talking about on
this podcast and we'll probably talk
about more in the future is just
the effects of community so we're
talking about a lot of the effects of
trauma on the brain but the effects of
community on the brain i mean that ties
back again to some of the oxytocin work
i will probably try and have larry young
on at some point as well i haven't told
him that yet so maybe he'll hear that
through this
but i think you know just the importance
of that community component and how that
intersects
on so many levels with the processes in
the brain that you've both been studying
for
for years and then some of these just
inherent
gut feelings that we have as human
beings as we interact
i mean we do again as a neuroscience i
like to focus on the brain but some of
these things we can really just feel in
ourselves even
as we've lost some of that with all the
zoom conversations so i did want to
mention that and just say that i think
that's another just key component
and getting back to what bianca said
about the biology is there to
protect us in a way and some of that i
think is through community
and obviously there's a lot of research
that backs that up as well
well but again there's so much i feel
like this conversation could have gone
for many many more hours
uh definitely i mean i think there's you
know there's lots of data that for your
next topic you know
exactly both in in bianca and our young
and tom enzo and others work on
oxycodone community and then you know
work
by many's including some of our work
showing that community cohesion
buffers childhood trauma on the effects
of adult ptsd
and that you know one of the biggest
supporting factors that matters no
matter how bad your life is
if you have you know one or two strong
adults who are there supporting you and
you have that support system that can
buffer so much
difficulty and so i think whether that's
through church whether that's through
the local y
whether it's through the coach or
whatever that community is so critical
for survival and for for
resilience and being strong yeah
so important so important it's the
greater green network
of community yeah we have our brains
connected to different neurons but we
don't live individually we as human
like oxytocin is there and it's a bigger
global brain i think that
we can't forget about yeah well well
you're both leaving me hungry for more
i imagine that our listeners are feeling
the same way yeah
yeah so if you'd both be one i
definitely would love to have you back
and continue this conversation
again just really grateful to both of
you for being willing to jump on
early in this adi hour uh
initiative that we're getting off the
ground here i think these conversations
have been great and there's so much i
think that's going to really
be important for our listeners and
things that people can really grab onto
so
appreciate both of you both uh dr bianca
jones marlin dr kerry ressler for
jumping on the adi
hour today uh this has been just yeah i
know i'm gonna be i'm already still
thinking through everything that you've
got um so much more to chew on but
grateful for the for the chance
for both you to be here and contribute
this way thank you thank you so much for
inviting and having me i really
appreciate it
thanks so much and bianca great to see
you really fun conversation
yeah it's been a pleasure